the intel report on covet is out and
they have said they have no idea that
that's it okay uh
we were all uh excited you know we're
sitting here with steve bannon he's like
look you know the intel reports coming
out we'll see what they say and i'm like
oh man and you know we had a bunch of
other people and they're all excited and
they're like it may coven may have
leaked from the huan lab maybe we don't
know
we're divided
nothing definitive but there is a lot of
news still in afghanistan and i gotta be
honest guys you know i i do think the
afghanistan stuff is probably the most
important but at a certain point it's
like
we've talked about it so much i have
talked about it so much that i want
we're going to talk about it obviously
but i wanted to lead in with something
else just because the afghanistan stuff
is some of the most depressing and dark
stuff and then it reminds you and i hear
right here i go reminding you that
there's the emperor has no clothes so
it's creepy stuff also interestingly in
the news this may come as a surprise to
many of you but milo yiannopoulos has
been censored
again on youtube apparently he got
banned off youtube uh you know where he
was still allowed and i you know a lot
of people uh
i guess haven't heard from him in a long
time because of the censorship but uh
censorship is still happening so we'll
definitely talk about that and we're
being joined by one of the experts on
censorship dan gainer
thanks i'm vice president for free
speech america to media research center
and we spend all our time trying to stop
what's become an absolute madness on the
internet taking away all of our freedom
to speak to say anything
it was awful before and then coveted
just went insane because they
feel you've now got the president united
states and the surgeon general who are
trying to force the social media
companies to restrict speech yeah it's a
it's utter insanity so there's there's a
keeps me busy
there's a story right now from science
mag news guard certified science mag a
legitimate publication
talking about uh i think it's infection
rates or no no i'm sorry it's talking
about
likelihood of um what does it it's it's
you don't want to be too specific
because you know what's going to happen
to you well no no
it's about like um likelihood of
catching covid based on infection versus
vaccine or something like that yeah it's
talking about the immune response you'll
have based on uh getting it versus
getting the vaccination twitter has
censored it right it's a legitimate
study published by a legitimate
legitimate magazine science mag news
guard certified can't talk about it and
and we know this has been going on
because twitter you shut down the hunter
biden stories there was collusion
between big tech and the democratic
party to shut down negative stories
about biden and then we saw that
rasmussen poll that said if people were
aware of what joe and his son had done
you don't meaning like flying his son to
china on air force two and meeting with
his business partners people wouldn't
have voted for him that's the problem of
censorship well in the prom this
i've been on online since before the
world wide web
and which means hey i'm old and b i've
got this nice perspective when it was
when it was pleasant you when you had
like people talking online about the
guild you know and felicia day and
everything was nice and then
you know things started crazy in 2014
and then they got worse and worse in 15
to 16 with the election
and after trump won largely on the basis
of social media because he had a he was
a social media powerhouse the social
media companies in the left and
particularly in the traditional press
who are the biggest advocates for
censorship
they went in completely insane it just
determined okay you guys won with that
we're going to take it all even though
we call ourselves free seats america
that was when we launched i mean that
sort of our mindset now it's not about
free speech anymore because
it was before even kova but now because
of cove at everything you spend all of
your lives online you go to school your
kids do or you do you work you sell you
buy you go to see the doctor you
interact with your government you do
everything including banking and their
censor if they censor us online in those
then it's not an issue of free speech
it's simply are you a first class or
third class citizen simply civil rights
yeah exactly we'll get into all that
stuff we'll check out the website too we
got ian yeah as you're talking about
this i'm thinking of the frogs and the
pot and how we're slowly this is like oh
it's just a little bit of censorship
here a little bit there then all of a
sudden
you said the naughty word on the phone
they're taking your phone number away
you're not allowed to get a phone now
you're not allowed to have a social
media account now you're not allowed to
have a bank like it's completely
dehumanizing absolutely a violation of
human rights i'm glad you're here thank
you thank you
yeah i'm excited too as i already
pitched in because as soon as i saw this
thing on twitter i called my magic
special source who has two different
master's degrees including one in
biomedical sciences and i was like bro
bro is getting a disease better or worse
than getting the shot because with
chickenpox if you don't get shingles you
should get the shot you shouldn't just
get chickenpox and he was like it
depends on the virus depends on all the
stuff but there's no reason for twitter
to be censoring this so i'm really
excited to be talking about this before
we get started head over to timcast.com
become a member and you will get an
advertisement free experience as you
browse the website plus all of our
members only podcast from the tim cast
irl show and you'll be supporting our
fierce and independent journalists
that's awesome right that should be
enough but uh also like this video
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends it's friday night we
we chill a little bit on friday nights
we got this news
it's not really news it's nothing from
the new york post covid origen's report
says it's plausible virus leaked from
muhanlab york post reports
an unclassified summary of the u.s
intelligence community's report on kobe
19 says it's plausible the virus leak
from a lab in wuhan and that it might be
genetically engineered but investigators
remain divided i suppose at the very
least this you know now when the media
says it's a conspiracy theory
that it's a genetically modified lab
leak or something you can be like well
they said maybe
i'll take maybe right well i mean maybe
it means you can at least discuss it for
a year it was you know oh you went you
you went to the woodshed they took you
to which i beat you up a little bit
maybe maybe suspended you maybe banned
you for talking about something they
went after members of congress you know
yeah
that's well we that's so extreme we
mentioned this in a little bit dave
rubin got suspended like a week before
they announced booster shots for saying
booster shots were coming so so dave's
tweeting like they're gonna have booster
shots twitter suspends him and then like
a week later the new york times is like
booster shops shots have been announced
i think with dave it looked like he had
a lot of evidence showing that it was it
probably would happen and he i don't
know exactly what happened i imagine he
said it it is going to happen and that's
like crossing a line
saying that it's evident and that it
looks like it is very likely is very
different than saying it is but
journalists have been doing this for
basically the history of journalism
saying hey we've got sources saying that
this is going to happen i was talking
about this downstairs
you're not allowed to criticize the
world health organization or the cdc
basically by these social media
companies but then
new york times can run a story they did
they did a story at the end of 2019
right right at the end of the year about
the world health organization they said
one of the one of the givens of the
world health organization is that they
want you to keep open borders in the
middle of a pandemic which i think
ordinary people would go well that's
nuts but they they said oh it's this way
but then they dug into it it turns out
there's absolutely no scientific reason
for it it's simply their agenda to keep
the borders open
now why why we do this well because
we're supposed to listen to the sciency
people at the world health organization
well now the funny thing is you know uh
and we'll we'll give we'll give youtube
it's it's uh uh it's it's peace
in in all of the horse dewormer stories
you know it's the craziest thing seeing
every single outlet refer to ivermectin
as horse medicine because it's like
don't they give ibuprofen the dogs like
don't they you know what i mean yeah so
the issue is and for you youtube uh that
ivory version isn't fda approved there
are some studies going on right now but
it is not fda approved for treatment in
covid but it's also not horse medicine i
mean it technically is but it is fda
approved for certain uses like skate
like topical scabies and i think you
know general dewormer stuff the crazy
thing is how the the media is walking in
lockstep they're all saying horse
medicine
it's in a version of horse medicine but
it's also in other things i mean like
medicine we give antibiotics to horses
too yeah it doesn't make them horse
antibiotics right right right right yeah
but how the how the media is treating it
this way how like we have to even be
careful with bringing it up because
buddy who dares oh wait you said the
wrong thing i interviewed uh dr
zevzalenko
and he got
documents restricted by google docs now
if that is not
1984-ish oh you've got stuff you can't
share them to other human beings even
though you wrote them and they involve
documents that you sent to you know
to world leaders but you can't share
them to other human beings because
they're locked out
and i mean that that is there was a um
i think bit shoot was banned like
twitter had banned links to bit shoot
yeah or i think they still do it gives
you a warning and there was one thing i
tweeted about i can't remember what it
was but it was like if you tried to
tweet it it'll give you an error
and so they're like oops
site's broken that's all it is and then
you're like there's one link remember
when facebook banned minds
yes yeah yeah you couldn't send a
message a facebook message with
minds.com in the message or it would be
like this i can i can top that there are
people who are banned on facebook
not that they're not allowed to be on
facebook you cannot send their websites
by messenger on facebook they they
literally will not be able to send we
ran across it was a dentist a friend of
mine was trying to go to uh out in
arizona and like
i can't she was trying to send me the
link to the to the dentist but he does
some holistic health
and
couldn't couldn't do it we ran out the
hunting
group in dallas their their website was
banned on facebook even though it didn't
violate any facebook rules the facebook
you know authoritarians who don't like
hunting
banned them so you know looking back to
the the report which tells us literally
nothing you know the covet origins
report you are basically saying that at
least this allows us to talk about it
now right because before it was like if
you brought this stuff up you're a
conspiracy theorist you risk it to
restrict anything they don't like then
the people who enforce them are people
who restrict anything they don't like
and then the people you appeal to are
the people who restrict anything you
don't like it's kind of set up and of
course you get the fact checkers who are
just evil and moronic and they will also
restrict anything they don't yeah well
you know the thing about fact checking
is
all of these organizations that do fact
checking that go to the pointer
institute so that on facebook they can
remove you why don't conservatives set
up fact-checking organizations here's
why because the fact i just i've had
people ask us to do it because the
fact-checking network can also remove
you so you could spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars hiring people
setting up uh the operation it's very
tedious if you start fact checking cnn
cnn is going to call a pointer and
they're going to pull your authority and
then you're off and that's it you're
done because they control they they
control the whole game and what happened
was a whole bunch of journals got laid
off back after 2008 so they came up and
they journalists hate the fact that
people use what are called you know
alternative facts
and so they basically came up with a way
to gain the system
they now control the facts even though
most of the time what they're doing is
just narrative
yeah they don't care that oh well we
think your narrative is wrong you need
to include 60 more paragraphs yeah i got
fact checked by lead stories uh actually
it was an it was okay so here's what
happened i tweeted out something about
epstein like that and i remember the
exact tweet but everything i said was
factual
someone screen grabbed it and posted it
to facebook and then lead stories said
it was it was fake this this this tweet
is false information
and so i looked up i i i saw the tag on
my tweet screenshot it i didn't post it
and then it said false information
here's why i clicked it went to their
story which confirmed every single thing
in my tweet was correct when i called
the guy from the company he was irate
and yelling
and he was like i refuse to change it
and his argument was basically that the
way it was phrased in the tweet could
give the wrong impression and i said the
impression is irrelevant when my facts
are all correct what someone assumes
based on reading the tweet is irrelevant
i didn't say what you're accusing me of
saying something like bill clinton went
to epstein island or something which i
didn't say i can't remember exactly what
the tweet was
and then instead of instead of taking
down the fake fact check he left it up
but put you know like partially
incorrect or something like that
so
they can take a a fact and then call it
fake news and false information and then
explain on their end that well it is
technically true but we just want to
provide clear you know clarification so
now when you get hit on facebook and
facebook strips your monetization that's
that that's the end result well and what
they do is their favorite is the context
you know oh you don't have enough
context well by that definition the
entire freaking world doesn't have
enough context encyclopedia britannica
doesn't have enough context because oh
you didn't include this book full of
information about afghanistan or those
27 books about you know
you know pick your topic calculus oh
well there's not enough information
calculus in there so you need to add
more context we got hit by politifact
for
re-running a cdc chart okay so not doing
anything controversial here we re-ran a
cdc chart linked to a story about it and
that story linked back to the cdc
politifact
gave us a fact check and gave us sort of
like the trifecta of fact checks they
said okay well we lacked context but
then they called it partly false but
then he put a big you know huge red
capital letters false on our chart and
so we challenged that they of course
ignored it so what we did we got more
than 40 conservative organizations
together and sent an obnoxious letter to
the international fact-checking network
and said you got to pull their pull
their your card they are not fair we've
the media research center has tracked
more than 50 examples since 2019 where
they've been out of control yeah and i
we didn't really think they would do it
but so now that's got to be the
narrative every time politifact does
another lousy fact check people
go more than 40 organizations said this
organization should lose its
fact-checking ability do you see when
they uh i can't remember which
organization it was they flagged the cdc
itself as false news yeah
yeah so on facebook a link to the cdc it
was an article from the cdc where they
said that they were changing they were
encouraging new uh testing for covid
and so these facebook fact checkers
flagged cdc.gov as fake news
and you know the funny thing is
when i so there's there's people you can
reach out to at facebook if you're uh
one of the the better men in the
privileged elites like we all are here
i'm kidding in a sense like
but the reality is in this world if you
have a show and you have followers then
all of a sudden there's someone to talk
to at facebook but the regular people
they're they're kicked to the gutter so
i know i i have the contact emails i
have the connections and they said when
you get fact checked on facebook it's
not us it's those third-party companies
and i i argued
facebook has
given special privileged access that is
not public accommodation
to these people so you're effectively
outsourcing facebook's role in fact
checking to third parties i would argue
that is still facebook's responsibility
for defamation
if facebook is going to cl if if there
is going to be a box that says fake
information over my post and that is not
true as a statement of fact saying what
i put was false information
then i think facebook and that company
are responsible facebook said screw you
it's them do something about it so you
effectively have to just go after these
fact checkers and sue them for
defamation and and the reality is if
they called a cdc chart fake false
information that's not an opinion that's
a statement fact you gotta sue you gotta
sue for defamation and and of course you
know
these organizations who pays them
facebook
you know they get money from facebook
that's that's one of the so you're well
that's clear cut go for facebook yeah i
can say you make you mention lead
stories so we we did a big piece on lead
stories i guess probably 2019 my whole
sense of timing is screwed up because of
covet uh it's like half but uh we did it
and we slammed and they denied
everything we did yeah we said about
right after they launched their red and
blue feed to show that they were fact
checking both sides but here's the game
that these that it's not just them but
that facebook and all the companies play
when
they fact check somebody on the right
it's you know it goes gets scattered all
over facebook and attached to everything
that anybody posts about that but if
they do it for somebody left it doesn't
do that so if they fact check
uh you know some micro organization or
occupied democrats saying something
stupid because they're idiots uh you
know if they fact check them well then
they won't say oh by the way they were
actually citing something cnn did
they're not going to then attach that
fact check to cnn it just drops there
and so that's the way so what they've
set it up is it deliberately hurts
conservative organizations and anybody
who disagrees with the status quo which
i'm pretty sure is the people in this
room
yep i would say so
it's a broken system
i don't know what else to say we've been
dealing with with it for a long time and
i guess the challenge is it just shows
how dark things are continually getting
that we even move beyond this knowing
it's happening and nothing's changed
right we're now we're now at a period
where
we're we can't have discussions about
the science they tell us trust the
science and i'm like okay well a bunch
of scientists came out
not those scientists
i'm like well
who am i supposed to trust that and why
dr fauci but fauci's been wrong every
other day yeah well trust him
what about those doctors over there nope
all right i guess what about when fauci
outright you know got called out for oh
moving the goal post which we which in
civilized society we call lying through
his teeth but when when he did that or
when he lied about masking what about
when sanjay gupta is actually one of my
favorite little elements from from kovid
when
early march 2019 when sanjay or 2020 i
mean sanjay gupta had a town hall at cnn
where they had about 60 some people
packed you know
shoulder to shoulder in the audience not
wearing masks when gupta comes out and
says
on air that masking is dangerous
now gupta said that yeah
then oh suddenly they decide that later
on masking is good all right i'm okay
i'm okay with them doing that if they
keep saying by the way you know i said
this this dumb thing before and keep
putting it out there but what happens is
all that stuff gets memory hold every
time fauci does something or gupta does
something or any of these people they
say something that's wrong or you know
later on proven wrong there's no there's
no accountability for them there's only
accountability for us let's talk about
how dark things are actually getting
so let's step into this one from cnbc
congressional panel investigating
january 6 insurrection demands records
from facebook twitter and other tech
firms so here we go you may have heard
that the january 6 committee submit uh
submitted a letter to all these
different government agencies demanding
information on basically everybody in
the trump government as well as a large
number of activists
who are just
i mean scott pressler is the most
pressing example he's a guy who
registers republicans the vote he cleans
up garbage and they said they wanted
every every communication from the
government to him going back to april
1st of 2020 into january 20th of 2021
this guy has nothing to do with any of
it
my understanding he wasn't even in dc
during on january 6th
but this is their overreach and now it's
coming to the big tech firms which is
what we expected when we had jack
bosovich here who was on this list you
know the general idea we were talking
about is they'll eventually take it from
the government to social media companies
now all of these big tech firms who we
know are biased are going to start going
after trump supporters and activists
they're i'm willing to bet if you're
like some mid-level trump supporter your
communications your dms will probably
get leaked because they're going to
demand it and why why would facebook or
google say no they're going to be like
well you know it's very important we
help out here you go well look at look
at how the government tax forms for all
these rich people got leaked all of a
sudden
biden is talking about going after rich
people with his tax efforts oh and also
talking about throwing tons of money at
the irs
magically pro-publica gets a dump of the
tax for the tax records for a lot of
famous rich people and then starts
writing about it now you know
it's
oh remember we weren't supposed to talk
about the deep state oh deep state
doesn't exist until a guy from new york
times writes a book and says the deep
state that deep state exists and it's a
good thing it's a good thing because
it's on our side you know let's uh let
me read a little bit from here we got
this from cnbc they say the house select
committee investigating january 6
said friday it's demanding a trove of
records from 15 social media companies
including facebook twitter google and a
slew of pro trump platforms the request
for records stretching back to the
spring of 2020 are related to the spread
of misinformation efforts to overturn
the 2020 election or prevent the
certification of the results domestic
violent extremism or and foreign
influence in the 2020 election the
committee said in a press release
they're also looking into policy changes
that the social media companies adopted
or failed to adopt regarding the spread
of violent extremism misinformation and
foreign malign influence that includes
decisions on banning material from
platforms and contacts with law
enforcement and other government
entities the press release said the
committee's latest requests further
underscore the role of social media on
the capital attack blah blah blah blah
blah they
blamed parlor but it was actually
facebook where people were were getting
together and scheduling and planning for
the uh for for january 6. so uh the the
coordination coordination and collusion
i think is obvious and now
what's the chances that these companies
just turn over all this data and
everyone who is anti-establishment all
of a sudden has the worst possible
things they've ever said taken out of
context plashed all over the internet
every story possible and then what
happens next after that is the financial
institution starts saying oh oh oh geez
these stories yep gotta ban them well
financial institutions already are doing
some of that they did it too
as you can see one of the one of the
republican senate candidates in delaware
oh okay we can't we're not gonna allow
you we're gonna we're gonna shut down
your bank account we're gonna you know
you got paypal doing the same thing all
these companies but yes that is that's
an enormous insane uh stasi like uh you
know overreach of gov of government into
basically the lives of absolutely
everybody
yeah this is and you're right it's not
just but it's not just the they could
they could leak oh you you know you're
having an affair on your wife somebody's
you know oh you just you send a dirty
joke use
anything they want they can use against
you with that and unfortunately we all
and i've certainly found this category
we've all spent years
posting absolutely everything on social
media and then and beyond that they also
know who your friends are yeah so even
if you've not done anything wrong
they can go after your family members
okay you know you're you're you know
you're 50 years old you got kids who are
in their 20s oh you've never done you've
never even done speeding
but your kids oh well they've done
something wrong so hey we're going after
the kids now
there's that is that's just the most
broad insanity thing i've ever heard
government do it's very clear the path
that we're on where we're going and at a
certain point i'm kind of just like
i don't know what do we do do we just
you know kick back put your feet up and
wait for the tsunami to crash over in
public but you got to be super subtle
about how you change the system quietly
like how like by building technology
that yeah makes it building culture yeah
yeah like fetiverse projects things
where things that can't be censored or
that aren't censored by nature things
that are decentralized
stuff like that
you know cryptography and crypt um
cryptocurrency that's why they hate they
hate crypto so much they freak out about
it because that really does you know put
a uh
well they can they can
they can't monitor where your money goes
no they can't and but i mean but i mean
that's depending on which one you use if
you use like monero or zcash but bitcoin
is fully public right and they can
easily track all of it but i mean this
follows this follows chokepoint
you know when chokepoint went after when
after the the
i guess what the gun companies and other
stuff and
one after drugs you can't carry more
than ten thousand dollars of cash on you
because oh you might be right might be
making a drug deal then when they found
that people were carrying nine they cut
it back to eight
because they don't want you to you know
it's like we don't want you carrying
cash because you might actually buy
something we don't approve of and so now
if we catch you with eight thousand and
one dollars in your car
we can take it all yep civil asset
forfeiture they just steal your money
and you don't get it back amazing yeah i
wonder how that would play out if you're
like running like a burger shop and you
have like your day daily cash from the
right from the tails you're going to the
bank with it and they're like that's a
bank they stop you outside the bank and
they're like you're going to go buy
drugs but they're deposited they're like
every day and the only re and i guess
when you're a frog in a pot and the pot
starts slowly coming to a boil people
just don't know and don't care but i
people need to stop and just think about
a few things what is it is it shock if i
told you that you have a a a a serial
number right you're with the government
for your person
not for me no nothing nothing i mean my
my level of shock is
kind of gone up a lot you know like what
it takes to shock i think if i went home
and i found police cars surrounded
prized by like i don't think that
reaches shock isn't it a crazy idea when
you realize that like every single
person in the u.s is serialized with a
specific number that identifies you
every citizen yeah it's like something i
remember i'd grow up and i'd see like
movies where people would get numbers
and stuff like that and how wrong and
bad it was and then it's like but we've
been doing this since what is like 1916
or something social security numbers not
unique since fdr era so when was that
30s 30s yeah yeah so you want to almost
anything you need a social security
number you need to be registered with
the government now you've got new york
city saying you need to you need a photo
id state issued in order to get access
to any of these buildings it's weird
like if you go to the restaurant hey i
want to get i want to get carrie out
sorry you can't come in no no no no no
no carrie is okay
but if you can't come in the building no
you can unless you show your id no no no
no no it the the law exempts carryout oh
okay yeah yeah i don't know why
apparently if you have covet but you're
only going to be in for carryout you
can't cough on people or something also
i learned something really interesting
is that when uh when you when you first
walk in
you're wearing the mask because covid
sits high
but when you sit down you're underneath
it i'm kidding by the way i have no idea
what that policy is it's like you walk
into a restaurant i was talking to a
restaurant on the phone and i was like
they were like oh you've got to wear
masks regardless of vaccination status
and i was like okay and i was like but
then when i sit down i can take it off
they're like yes and i was like does
that make sense and the guy was like
i don't know they just make me do it and
i'm like
yo that's ridiculous dude like uh
whatever man people just keep people
just follow along they march along with
all this stuff well i mean do you look
at australia right now it's not just
march alone but i mean they're all
locked in their homes again i mean how
many i've lost track i saw somebody post
a chart of how many lockdowns australia
has had since since covet this is the
they're going on the eighth i think
7th or 8th oh youtube's mad at us right
now yeah they're giving us trouble yeah
so i'm i'm checking the feed and i'm
seeing it keeps cutting out yeah we've
got full internet we've got our
internet's what spicy things are we
talking about might be us i think ben
and andreas were going to work on the
internet today so there was some issues
no i'm looking at the connection we're
solid interesting we have a solid
high-speed connection right now
yeah i'll start singing uh avenue q for
you know maybe they'd be happy if we
talk about that talk about porn you know
i just wanna i
there is something that needs to be said
though it needs to be said ian okay you
people need to hear this oh here we go
mark zuckerberg is such a good guy he's
just yeah he's so fun you know and jack
dorsey good haircut
what a good guy
he's just co-opted by the corporation
right now
dorothy's also now he moved in from the
i've got the crazy like 400 mile beard
into i'm now dating supermodels so he is
going through a little bit of a phase
midlife crisis yeah
he got all the career stuff out of the
way he's just he's he's a figurehead for
twitter you know he left the company
he's doing square square's doing really
well and then they brought him back
because they needed someone to take
responsibility i guess so he i don't
even know why he does it
i don't i don't make sense to me that
dude's got he's a billionaire like what
does he get that he's maybe he feels
like just by still having a tether with
it he can still kind of
make it keep it from going totally
insane but
when a company buys you out man that's
their company now it's not it's not his
company anymore so yeah it's like a skin
suit
yeah but you know look
actions speak louder than words i
suppose uh did you see when jack dressy
tweeted out rothbard the anatomy of the
state like all the libertarians and
handicaps were like they're like
high-fiving each other and they're like
yeah actually they're probably freaking
out like our friend luke was like what's
happening
jack dorsey's nose but uh but i think
some of this is a lot of what we see now
on social media from famous people is
them just screwing with us
and i mean i think because they know
they that it changes the narrative and
everybody talks about them again that's
what he does on twitter yeah that's what
tim does it's like it just screws with
people oh i love social media it's like
andy kaufman but to be fair i'm just
following i'm just uh following michael
malus you know oh yeah michael males is
a pro i tweeted uh joe biden is the
greatest president of this or any
generation and then i waited a few
minutes and then i replied why aren't
you retweeting this
and it got it got like a thousand
reviews or something it got like 2 000
replies but the funny thing is like
i'll tell you exactly why i did a tweet
like that
because you have establishment left
activists and how do they respond to
that tweet
i said something very very complementary
to joe biden but the implication is
it's
sarcasm
so the interesting thing is that
establishment democrat type activists
completely ignore tweets like that and
that i do that it kind of kind of proves
a point
you know there was uh uh when i when i
when i was tweeting about vaccine medics
being wrong i get all of these
establishment democrat activists being
like
you're crazy you're wrong there will be
medical exemptions everyone's got to
pitch in and then when i called all of
these restaurants and i called new york
city and they said no medical exemptions
period
the same activists were nowhere in sight
no longer replying no longer arguing
they could have replied with like wow i
didn't see that coming in fact i even d
i i sent messages to cameron caskey the
act the parkland activist because we had
interacted on the idea of medical
exemptions we were talking i tweeted
about google
mandating uh vaccines and said i wonder
how many people are gonna are gonna quit
their jobs or lose their jobs and he
said he was he responded there's about
to be a lot of openings for people who
aren't stupid and then i was like some
people have medical issues bro and he's
like well there will be exemptions so
when this thing with new york happened i
just i in good faith i was like hey just
wanted you to see this because i know we
had interacted on it no response because
these people aren't acting in good faith
if i come out and say something like you
know joe biden should do x and then
someone argues with me and then joe
biden goes and does x i'll be like well
you know i should i got to eat my words
joe biden just did it but that you don't
see that from most tribalists and you
look at look at what's happening
imminently to the military now we've got
hundreds of thousands of people in the
military who are not vaccinated
and we're going around
celebrating our heroes in afghanistan
and you know and
you know the left and the right are both
like oh my god you know we love the
military the military but then
they're gonna turn around in a week or
two and a whole bunch of those people
are gonna what be called caught up in
charges court-martialed or get some sort
of you know pushed out of the military
at a time when our military can't afford
it and all just like they said the
frontline healthcare workers oh my god
we love the nurses and the doctors going
at risk in their lives oh wait they're
not getting the vaccine that's it for
them and they literally they throw them
out of a moving car
and and so you know it's the
inconsistency the person person who
doesn't get the vaccine to chose for
whatever reason doesn't get the vaccine
if they're out there risking their life
for their country or or saving lives and
as a health care worker they're still
the same darn person that was doing that
so i want to i want to show this here uh
anatomy of the state so
most of you uh maybe if you missed it we
we're just mentioning how jack dorsey
the ceo of twitter ever woke
tweeted out
murray rothbard
anatomy of the state libertarians and
anarcho-capitalists were all hooting and
hollering and freaking out and on page
six which is you know the opening of
anatomy of the state which jack dorsey
himself posted
the greatest danger to the state is
independent intellectual criticism
it's very interesting that uh jack
dorsey would tweet something like that
out considering twitter actively tries
to suppress intellectual criticism of
the state
maybe maybe jack he's like he's actually
locked in a basement
and he's like you know and they run
everything and he he broke out and he's
all gaunt and frail and like they're
coming to bring his food and the door
opens and they're like here's your food
dorsey and then he shoves the guy out of
the way and he runs the computer and he
hits control c control v and then he say
enter and they're like no and they grab
him they're dragging him back and he's
like no freedom
and he can like see the matrix as he's
being pulled back and they throw him
back in the room don't you ever pull
something like that again and then you
know uh the other twitter execution he
escaped from his cell and he tweeted out
rothbard and then they were like oh can
we delete it no the next time he
testifies in front of congress we'll
have to watch as he blinks to see if he
blinks
he's got like uh he's got like a brain
chip he's like a thing on his temple and
it like shorts out for a second and he's
like i can i can think again and he goes
to the computer and he sends it and then
they're like oh guys you got to reboot
dorsey's mind control chip
and he goes
like the v chip from south park
yeah
yeah so or the rogan podcast and he was
talking about blockchain and i think
he's really naive i think he doesn't
know
he doesn't talk about i think he's uh to
be completely honest nice guy a bit
duplicitous uh right place in right time
twitter is not particularly complicated
he's he said we discovered twitter we
didn't invent twitter things like that
and when i was talking to him um before
we did the rogan podcast like literally
like minutes before he was saying how he
really wanted blockchain based social
media
and he was like that way once it's there
it's like there forever and i'm like
that sounds horrible that sounds like
the worst idea ever like imagine you're
15 you know when you're like i'm gonna
post a picture of my ass cause i'm edgy
and i got 10 followers and i don't care
and then you're 30 and you're like you
know you've got 50 000 followers now and
you're a sports commentator and then
they're like good now but noticed in
your immutable ledger use a picture of
your ass it's like
i know i can't get i can it's in the
blockchain what am i supposed to do
about it it's there forever in theory
what that should mean is that we all
kind of get that to get out of jail free
for doing dumb stuff but what it what in
practice it means is if you did dumb
stuff that the elite don't approve of
you know you can get cancelled at
absolutely any point in time in your
life but if they are okay with the dumb
stuff you know you you know you are part
of you know an anti-far you know attack
or something oh yeah that's fine we
don't care that's fine you get a nice
reuters article
you were once a noble activist fighting
for justice tell me how that went well i
threw a bunch of bottles at people and
then we went around smashing things oh
wow sounds like fun sounds like you've
accomplished a lot in your life yes it
was hard but we burned down some bars
that's basically the the history of
these people when they're older there's
a video uh that went viral of um a
journalist
who is trying to cover what's going on
in portland and this antifa gets in her
face and says that like you are
endangering people by spreading kovid
which is like the craziest thing for
antifa i guess to say they're pro state
whatever and then they they they
physically attack her throw to the
ground spray with paint and mace or
whatever
these people
they
they're effectively
around the brown shirts you know they're
they're enforcing state edict or
whatever they march around these cities
doing literally nothing
believing cnn and thinking they oppose
the state when they're doing everything
the state would want them to do
yeah i mean the brown shirts entirely
they say oh we're we're the original
anti-fascists and they you know post
images you'll see idiots like people at
cnn posting images of you know d-day
landing and like oh you know
anti-fascists and then comparing them
chris cuomo uh you know to antiphon and
i'm like no these are
the worst of the gutter trash who go
attack ordinary people on the street
and
try to bully people just because they
think or say different things i don't
support anybody doing that i don't care
what ideology you've got if you're going
and just walking up to please speaking
we've proven that do you see when they
were attacking people who are protesting
code restrictions
i'm like isn't that weird the state
comes out and makes like like bill de
blasio decrees something that's like not
even a law it's a decree from executor
and they're like we're going to defend
that and so you come out and be like the
there was actually an event happen in dc
where a bunch of conservatives came down
to protest corporate censorship
and antifa showed up calling them
fascists and started attacking people
and i'm like yo are they
are they pro corporation
is like antifa
pro
oh dude they're fashion racism because
it's a word game to manipulate people
who don't pay attention right it's about
the same thing yeah you know we've
replaced we've we've gone full circle
where now the very people who go around
saying oh you can't be racist are then
going around saying racist stuff you can
get shut down on twitter or social media
for saying anything racist in some
groups but not against others and it's
the game look at the the anti-semitism
you see on these sites is just off the
charts and you see it not just on social
media but on
you know in schools and colleges
universities
the jewish you know the these jewish
students everywhere are now
a target when they go to college i you
know that's the exact kind of thing
that we look back at history books and
say gee that was awful when it happened
in the 1930s why are we allowing it to
happen here in
this era
yeah
i i love uh i'm just reading you know i
have the anatomy of the state pulled up
and just for jack dorsey to tweet
something referring to the state is
parasitic and sapping production and
stuff like that i'm like wow
maybe he should apply those principles
to the companies that he runs you know
maybe things would get a little bit
better
but uh i hate to say it themes it just
seems like things are getting worse and
worse and even even with what's going on
in afghanistan and everyone kind of
turning their back on biden it's not
it's not in any way to imply that things
will improve no i mean i think
unfortunately look i i thought we
shouldn't be in afghanistan anywhere
near the length of time we were i mean
it
if you follow anything about history we
changed the mission
our military is really good at going and
kicking somebody's ass just is now but
they're not good at forcing you to come
into the 21st century and embrace
western values it's just
it's unfair ask of anybody and so they
went from being
war fighters to
prison guards and social workers and
that's just you know i don't care
whether you're carrying the ak-47 or m16
or whatever you're carrying
if you're trying to convince somebody
to join the 21st century when he you
know he can't even read
that's just the wrong mission that's why
it's a hundred it's a 100 year mission
you have to raise several generations
and instill in them like a norm but to
go into a country where there's al like
you know we're there we're there for 20
years
if you went to the american people and
said we want to be here for a hundred
years to colonize and reclaim people
would be like get out of here they would
not support that well it's also it's
also geographically really difficult
afghanistan is a landlocked nation we're
we're the world's greatest navy okay
that's just bad dynamics so if you're
going to do it and it didn't work well
when we did it in vietnam
i mean so because
you have to look it's just like when you
go buy a house i'm i drive out here get
the
wonderful compound see see the nice area
when you buy a house you buy a
neighborhood well afghanistan's in a
really bad neighborhood it's got
pakistan next door and they're run by
looney tunes people it's got china next
door they're even worse russia's nearby
you know i mean it is iran yeah it's
it's a mess
and it's exactly the same problem i mean
vietnam had when you've got china a
nation now of 1.3 billion people nearby
and you're another nation trying to end
up with a sane destiny it doesn't matter
whether you're taiwan or afghanistan
you're going to have trouble
yeah
well how about uh we take a look at
what's going on over in afghanistan we
have this story it's pretty interesting
tucker carlson questions if biden admin
botched afghanistan withdrawal on
purpose and we got some more stories to
potentially back up the claim that joe
biden screwed up afghanistan on purpose
tucker carlson pondered whether or not
the administration deliberately botched
the afghan withdrawal during his show
thursday evening
carlson's guest glenn greenwald was
discussing how there are elements in the
political establishment that would like
us to remain in afghanistan the
conversation led to the host questioning
if there was a possibility there was an
interest in screwing up to justify
future engagement quote i never want to
be a conspiracy not at all but i mean
everything you said is true so far so is
it worth at least wondering this is such
an obvious screw-up you you and i have
no experience running a military or
logistics withdrawal i can't even
organize my garage but even you and i
would probably do a better job of
withdrawing than these guys
it was just like it was comically bad is
it possible that an interest in making
it bad to justify future engagement or
is that too much to even speculate about
well i give you the story from the daily
mail glenn beck claims u.s state
department and biden's white house are
blocking his efforts to rescue afghan
christians from the taliban who want to
set them on fire
why
would they tell someone with the
capability of helping in the evacuation
not to why would they block that
unless
they want the chaos
so they can justify remaining well i'm
going to give i think there's there's
some legitimate reasons and some
illegitimate reasons i mean the
illegitimate reason they they don't want
to be shown up yeah they don't our
troops are not allowed to have not been
allowed to leave the airport area to go
rescue americans elsewhere in kabul much
less the rest of afghanistan but
you know if you flip it around if you're
trying not to have a confrontation with
the taliban and trying to get everybody
out and you've got random elements out
there who let's just say are more
cowboy-esque and willing to fight if
they've got to well then government's
gonna then then the taliban's gonna see
that as as engagement across the board
and then our troops are fighting so i i
can see that but what i can't see is
when the state department rejects would
you get people to the airport the state
department says sorry you can't come in
yeah now that
their our state department is not
requiring all the paperwork for
everybody gets there that they're
getting out so then you look it more it
looks more like hey you showed us up you
made us look bad let me make a better
point
the morning of the attacks
the us and the uk warned their citizens
to stay away
the
marines who lost their lives were also
briefed
that there was potentially going to be
an attack
they were still told to process afghan
allies
something doesn't add up here
think about this in full context
you've got marines at the at the gates
checking ids for afghan allies to bring
them in
the u.s says someone is going to try to
attack us american citizens stay away
but we'll still board afghan allies so
they tell the americans no you're not
you're you can't come right now because
it's a threat
these people are welcome to get on the
plane and many of them did they're not
they weren't worth as much
but something doesn't make sense this is
this
this to me is is well beyond a mistake
for all i know the us government could
have planted the freaking bombs and lied
about it it's still we're in conspiracy
world what the heck's going on in
conspiracy world we're talking about a
fact that they issued a warning saying
americans stay away they told the
americans not to come and then told the
marines to keep processing the afghan
citizens and then a bomb went off
killing marines and afghan citizens and
the reason why there weren't americans
there is because they were told not to
be there but 13 americans died u.s
marines
who are still down there checking ids at
the airport
why weren't they pulled from from the
from the checkpoints well why didn't
they say if we can't get americans out
we ain't getting anybody out and we're
not going to risk the lives of our
troops no they said stay at your post
the someone's going to attack us we
won't let those americans die but you
your cannon fodder that's just what they
did there it is i can't imagine that it
was an accident no immediately after it
happened you get biden come out and say
we're gonna go after whoever did this at
a time of our choosing at a place of
basically saying just so you all know
this is a green light for us to reinvent
or to re-attack we're gonna hunt
them remember they're also talking about
blowing up all the vehicles and
and aircraft that we left so you know
you talk about oh ongoing relations with
the taliban but by the way hey you know
those jets are flying over your country
blowing up your stuff you know they're
ours yeah you know i
and when we've
we made it clear we're not getting
everybody out you know we we know we're
not getting everybody out so then
what happens the first time because the
taliban is not a top-down organization
it's not you know it's not like the us
military where when the president gives
an order you expect a private somewhere
seven thousand miles away to do exactly
what the president ordered so let's say
the first time taliban not just chops
off the head of an american but
live cast it somewhere you know spreads
the video on the internet
what are we gonna do about it i mean
that's this is gonna be an ongoing thing
how many hundreds or thousands of
americans and then also american allies
and are going to be left there
and you know it's
so i mean whether you like it or not
it's certainly been botched you're right
we could have done we could have gotten
the dnd group from downstairs we could
have planned a better exit using you
know using miniatures
and uh i just want to uh
stress this point that needs to be said
because it it it needs to be questioned
in a he there needs to be a hearing this
needs to be brought up if they said
there is an imminent attack and
americans should stay away
but then told the marines to keep
working to process non-citizens for
transport something doesn't make sense i
think they were taking a risk like they
knew there was a probable attack but you
can't shut down just based on enough to
not evacuate american citizens enough to
say we will leave americans behind enemy
lines
something doesn't make sense if what is
joe but look
we're we're we're hearing wild estimates
some say a thousand to 2000 americans
still in afghanistan some say 35 to 50
000 who knows yeah that's some people i
don't know if that's true or not nbc
reported 15 000 then there was ap
reporting four thousand four hundred
evacuated so let's say maybe ten
thousand we don't know and when the
biden administration's asked they won't
say
so we don't know
but it was enough to say americans
should not come for evacuation but not
enough to say
marines should should stop processing
you know i mean you could argue that
they're trying to clear the the crowd
around you know around the area so we
can get americans out but the problem is
the crowd doesn't dissipate it's
millions of people you can as soon as
you clear out people who are around the
airport more people come right because a
whole bunch of people in particular in
kabul
want to get out you know if you're a
woman why i mean and you have some
opportunity to get out why would you
want to say in the you know 7th century
uh lunatic asylum where you're going to
be sex slave and
you know that's just your entire future
not to be able to you're not going to be
out of the burqa you're not going to be
able to educate you're not going to be
able to educate your kids
the kids will be taken and basically put
into military training why would you
want to stay so i understand why people
want to get out but
yeah
it's
it's like they they they said well we've
planned out every eventuality clearly
they did not that's a lie unless they
did and this is what they want
because i mean take it to its logical
conclusion if they if they did plan
every contingency oh wow so this is on
purpose well so why did we feel why did
we close bagram air base i mean that's
really the big question you you don't
have to say we would take the whole
you know exit plan to buy to buy from
but why do we close the base that's
isolated and safe and you don't have
really high buildings around where
snipers could you know shoot at you and
stuff like that
um something's wrong
this this is
you know part of me wants to believe
that biden fell asleep during a meeting
and kamala and millie and the other you
know uh members of his administration
were just kind of like uh so early lunch
and then got up and walked out like we
don't care that's on him not us he's the
one who's gonna you know be be uh
attacked in the media who's gonna blame
us huh
well it turns out a lot of people yeah
and i mean not just buck stops with
biden and he's getting the most the heat
right but it's not just and to be fair
it's not just one party it's not just
one group of generals this is 20 years
of everybody owns this
and you know we've left
600 000 rifles
600 000 rifles in there
thousands of vehicles couple hundred
aircraft we left 85 billion dollars
worth of hardware
and i'm sorry i find it hard to believe
that
that's entirely accidental that you're
right
you're seeing idiocracy oh love
idiocracy uh mike judge man
oh yeah i just saw it a week ago yeah we
were watching it it's a documentary yeah
yeah yeah well so so you know i think
about how uh he you know mike judge took
this concept of like
if if nature just um rewards those who
reproduce the most what would happen and
i'm like let's let's let's take let's
let's uh
imagine a future
based on
american foreign policy in the middle
east and what it leads to so you've got
you know isis
you've got the supporting of this of
syrian rebels and and arms dealing not
to mention fast and furious with the
cartels and you could make an idiocracy
where it's like after hundreds of years
of the us going into foreign countries
for intervention losing and then leaving
behind hundreds of millions of dollars
in supplies the world ends up with like
massive armed factions with like
american level technology in all these
different parts of the globe all going
to war and just blowing each other up
you end up with like
just 50 different isis isis a b c d e f
g h i j k l m n o p and they're all in
different regions all with black hawks
and f-15s bazookas and hundreds of
thousands of rifles be a good video game
yeah the year is 2130. america just
pulled out of its 87th attempt
here you go
like why did they decommission the
planes why didn't they melt them down
well they were broke because we left all
this stuff for the afghan army i'm gonna
i have to lift my other arms i can do
air quotes for afghan army i don't
really blame the afghan you know the
soldiers they lost 50 000 guys in 20
years fighting fighting against the
crazy taliban but their leaders were
corrupt their leaders were you know were
evil we weren't allowed to stop that uh
you know
the fact that it fell apart so fast
because they tried to create a modern
army for people who were not ready for
and kurt schlichter uh explained this
was saying that we built a a modern
american style army with massive amounts
of logistics which is like the backbone
of any our army it was massive logistics
and then we removed the logistics from
the yeah when binding down when biden
pulled and said you know we're pulling
out he wouldn't allow the contractors
back in well the contractors were
maintaining the air force well they they
had a land-based army that was counting
on air you know air support and
and you know of course that they
realized hey you guys built the wrong
army you left us you left us out hanging
out to dry
we built
like some pentagon fantasy army you ever
played command and conquer yeah
they should they should have built tesla
coils just all over there's still time
this is this is really the og gaming
night this is
great we're whipping out command and
conquer man for those that aren't
familiar with the reference and command
and conquer is like what's like an
isometric strategy game where you build
you collect resources tiberium and then
similar to starcraft yeah so there's
something you can build i think tesla
tesla coils are not right they're like
the battery yeah or is that red alert
did not have right
or is that only the second one in red
alert i think that's right alert when
this is okay right alert right right
soviets so uh awesome game by the way
dude
so you build towers and they're tesla
coils and when anyone gets close it just
zaps them with a vault of lightning and
just that was how i learned about the
word tesla i didn't know what i never
heard the name before that's how how
buried that guy was we were talking
about we got weeds okay we got like
weeds they're growing everywhere and we
used to have this really nice like trim
around the porch of wood chips
and the weeds started growing and just
nobody really paid attention within like
a month it's just a jungle right
so i got a weed whacker but the weeds
are too overgrown and the whacker broke
so i was like what what do we do i'm
like we can take we have these throwing
axes i'm like what if we bolt the
throwing axe to the weed whacker
and then everyone's like that's a really
really bad idea yeah this is gonna eject
a hatchet you know if you're standing
next to it hold on and so i said what if
we took the magnetron out of a microwave
attached it to the end of a two by four
put a soup can on it direct the
microwaves and then carried one of those
high power batteries we have in our
backs and created a portable active
denial system and then we could point
that which would effectively boil the
water in the weeds and kill them
and then i realized whoa we can build a
portable active denial system that's
kind of crazy cool
active denial system is a microwave
weapon the military uses to make people
feel like they're on fire and i'm like
that's kind of crazy i'm sure your
neighbors would just love to know that
you built one of those we don't really
have neighbors i mean kind of you have
to walk quite a bit for the most part
but uh
i don't i don't know what the law is on
this is not do it i i think i would
recommend at least while we're on
youtube right now saying that you're not
planning on building
or we can plan on it
hold on
you there's videos on youtube showing
you how to do it
yeah so when you put the soup can or i
think they might use a pringles can it's
like depending on the frequency of the
microwaves it focuses it and so this is
really cool they do these experiments
where they'll take up two by four put
the magnetron on it plug it in and
they'll point it at fluorescent lights
and they'll light up
that's like it's crazy right like
wireless energy yeah and this is a
little a little maybe not off topic but
a bigger picture i can't wait what is on
time
i can't stand the nanny state trying to
like protect and control the mind
because it's this we have access to the
most dangerous and epic equipment at all
times we have open flame for instance
fire it's like yeah you gotta you can
get your own flamethrower and it's the
those are illegals the opportunities
depending on where you are though like
for a human to experiment with dangerous
technologies part of how we've developed
and become what we are as a species so
to think that we could ever mute that
for the safety of our our species is in
my opinion just is illogical so so
here's what i'll say
when i when i look at uh
afghanistan and this conventional
warfare they do i'm wondering why they
aren't focused on non-conventional means
so uh i'll give you a gaming example for
the for the gamers you're familiar with
uh you played d did you play magic
gathering anything uh sorry you're
familiar with in-game meta so for those
that aren't familiar this means like
if there is a style of play in a sport
let's say um mma a lot of people know
mma
the the mma guys all learn very specific
things because there's
you know
certain styles are more efficient more
effective in the long run so people
decide i'm going to learn these you know
certain martial arts for these
circumstances
but then what happens is one day someone
says i'm going to do something totally
unconventional that they're not
expecting and they throw something into
the mix that may be risky but these guys
didn't train for that upsets what's
called the meta so
you know i when i think about this
conventional warfare like the taliban
it's been 20 years they know exactly
what the u.s has in terms of armaments
why didn't the u.s actually start
implementing
less conventional like new technologies
new strategies new methodologies and it
may be true i mean we know about active
nile systems they've used in afghanistan
and iraq i believe but there's a bunch
of things they could have done laser
induced plasma channels i joke about the
tesla coil but laser induced plasma
tower technology has been around for for
some time now they can literally point a
a a machine at you that strikes you with
lightning
there's a lot of things that
with something like that and enough
power to the system you wouldn't need to
aim
it would literally just be a big block
and if the enemy approached it
yeah but you're talking basically the
the apocalypse now solution the colonel
kurtz you know the you're the guy who
who goes you go the u.s government's
fighting the war the wrong way in
vietnam so i'm going to fight the right
way and go native and you know do things
differently
that's but
that's that is part of the problem we
built a modern army i will i will stress
too i i haven't gone over there yeah i'm
sure there's some dude who's like this
guy's an idiot well you can say this but
we're just discussing what you're
talking about simply breaking the rules
i they're i'm uh
much less now than i used to be a
football fan nfl but i'm from baltimore
baltimore ravens broke the rules the nfl
says you're going to zig everybody went
to the quarterbacks going to throw along
and all the ravens said well we're going
to have the the world's biggest rushing
attack and they then you know that i
mean low orbit ion canada i was on the
receiving end of that as a browns
factory well there you go i mean that's
and so
if you try something for 20 years and
the taliban's still there well you would
you would think you're getting bigger
and getting bigger my theory is that
they didn't ever want to destroy the
taliban they want to work with the
taliban they always did they knew they
wanted to convince them to join they
realized that wasn't going to happen now
they want to make them the government
and ally with them from afar basically
it was focused on isis it was just it
was justification for staying in the
country well i think i say because i
mean then you get into it is a
legitimate question that journalists
have not dug into is the
military-industrial complex and where
did all the generals who were in
afghanistan go to work after they left
and how much money did they make it how
many of them were living in nice big
houses now and now same for the
politicians that then went to work for k
street i mean those are these are the
questions that
when you see articles
you know in major media right now saying
oh well apparently all the
soldiers in afghanistan who were
training the afghan soldiers realized
this was all going to fall apart that
what we were setting up was flawed from
very beginning and then you look okay
well then why can't we dig into that
that's what journalists should be doing
that's that's a legitimate i don't care
whether you're left or right i don't
care who made the decision i i mean like
i said 20 years there's a lot of people
on both sides who might be tied to this
that's what major media are for to do
that digging
but because to do that digging you've
got to also alienate the washington
inside the beltway class
because they don't want
that kind of digging because it's going
to make them all look bad you know what
i'm really upset by i tweeted at elon
musk you know maybe a year or so ago why
aren't you built why haven't you bought
an iron man suit yet and he responded
with working on starship and now i said
that is an acceptable response um
the reason i highlight that is that
what do people do when they become
wealthy and successful
boats
women dumb stuff jewelry
it's like how many people are actively
doing crazy stuff like elon musk is very
very few i bring that up uh i don't want
to derail too much but when you look at
what the u.s does it's 20 years of
conventional warfare the exact same
thing we're doing i'm just wondering
where's the low orbit ion cannon you
know what i mean just like
like selectively targeting i get it i
get it they have hellfire missiles and
they can very much still do that from
the air but i'm just saying
too many people think inside the box
they don't visualize outside of it and
because of this we spend 20 years doing
the same thing that's not working over
and over and over again putting our hand
on the stove and going out it burns ow
it burns out and we just don't stop we
never stop
and unfortunately i was gonna say
unfortunately then
the whole world looks at that and says
we don't learn and i know some military
people who have been you know who are
very worried about if the us ends up in
a confrontation particularly in in the
pacific because the pacific is a long
reach force we don't have land bases
like we do in europe where we have lots
of infrastructure and you know germany
and france and stuff like that
guam and hawaii but they're but they're
they're
far between and easier to target for you
know for missiles
did you know that our our uh our air
force was all isolated
centralized in one location i think it
was guam and then it was only recently
that we just took all of our air force
and spread it around around the pacific
like
china could have just one shot at our
entire air force
some people are asleep at the wheel of
this machine right now this is freaking
terrifying it's because we're the
children of the children of the children
of those who actually fought in the war
and so it's it's it's it's the uh you
know wealth only lasts three generations
we did not ex look at mark milley is a
politician and a bureaucrat he's got all
this decorated nonsense and he's like
white rage
and it's like this guy doesn't know what
he's doing or talking about he's a
politician that's that's how he gets
that position
how many people have actually you know
in leadership have actually gone into
comment i mean donald trump wasn't
wasn't a politician or in in the
military he was a businessman and he
still had more people uh liking what he
was doing but you get someone like joe
biden who's a career bureaucrat and
politician surrounded by career
bureaucrats they have no idea what's
going on no no experience and no no
understanding of how to maintain and
build a system like well and what's
what's worse is when you get a policy
where we've
reached now with government is
government officials aren't even good at
doing the one thing they should be good
at which is being government officials i
you know fdr for all of his flaws when
he was basically equivalent of king
where he's you know won presidency four
times yeah
i can't remember if it was in 42 or 43
somewhere out in virginia they
established an operation
to plan
post-war after we won
how to run germany italy and japan now
think about that when the war was still
wildly in doubt we're devoting efforts
to already plan to you know what happens
if we win so of course when we won we
had plans we had a bunch of people
trained we we were we were somewhat
ready for it
and then when you look
you know
iraq afghanistan
we weren't ready at all and we had years
and years our bureaucrats don't plan
like that so i mean the very thing you
want government to be good at
is big government i mean okay if you're
gonna at least you're gonna be big
government do it well i i think the
simple the simple solution may just be
that the us doesn't want the end of the
taliban they wanted an excuse to
maintain these positions they they
didn't want an end to isis you know look
under obama isis grows and grows and
grows under trump he just crushes them
and it's because for one isis was was
destabilizing syria in a lot of ways and
that's what the us i think was hoping
for and it gives the us a good excuse to
go in and do whatever they want oh no oh
geez we have to go to war because these
bad bad people and it's like yeah the
bad bad people that you're responsible
for look we we funded the mujahideen we
supported them and we we
made a mess of things
and that's all apparently we keep doing
but this is why politicians hated donald
trump
don the the rule of washington and you
see this in both political parties is
they never want issues to go away you
know it's why are we still fighting over
abortion on the right why because you
know republicans had both houses and the
presidency
and did nothing and they didn't do it
why because then if you remove the issue
if you end that fight everybody will
vote for you next time my god you're the
guy who ended abortion god bless you and
then the next time they say well what
have you done for me lately right and so
if you end an issue so nobody wants to
end the fight the same goes for the
military want to have a base yeah you
know they wanted bagram
air base for the end of time
i was like okay well why so they're the
generals are pouting you know oh my god
you took away our air base that we could
access all sorts of stuff in asia well
then be honest about it yeah it's okay
well we're going to be there we're not
going to ever leave because we we are
the bad guests we are the people who
show up in your in your home at 5 30 in
the evening and come 4 a.m after
everybody's left we're still sitting
there and we're saying hey you got some
more chips
yeah when we got there we kicked the
windows in and to get in and then we sat
down with m16s we're the we were
supposed to be there we're the guy at
the dinner party where everybody is you
know finishing off their plates and the
waiter comes out and says now would any
of you like dessert no no no i'll have
the souffle uh that takes 45 minutes sir
i'm okay it's a family guy joke i'm
stealing a family guy joke but yeah you
got a call from the fbi they're like
i'll have some yeah and then of course
and then you want everybody to you know
everybody divide up the check
right right oh i'll tell you this man i
once went out to dinner i got invited to
a dinner um when i was working at uh a
media company and they're like
we won't name any names we're i worked
for only two uh we're going we're going
to this very expensive restaurant which
i won't name
and you're invited to come and they were
like just ordering and ordering and like
bringing things out and they were like
get this get that get this and i'm like
eating my food and i'm like this is
really expensive stuff it was like a
hundred dollar plate but i'm like it's
cool cause i'm gonna get this thing and
then afterwards they're like so split it
okay
and the bill was the bill was like two
grand and i was like what there was like
there's like five of us or whatever i'm
like dude i
that's how they get you
and i'm like you're crazy that's a
that's a scene from the movie the paper
yeah
is that is that is that that's what
we're doing in the middle east i guess
now it's it's crazy to see i think that
the the eu leaders in the uh uh in the
uk were saying like biden's lost it
they've gotten good they're they're
calling them out they're they're
condemning him you screwed this up blah
blah blah and uh
yeah well the the one thing we've not
talked about from this is because you
talked about the eu what is going forget
the
couple hundred thousand people we get
out of afghanistan there are 38 million
people in afghanistan and you know the
taliban is not exactly going to really
focus on borders 38 million people yeah
in afghanistan so they're not going to
they're not going to be focused on
border control so how many
people from afghanistan
start the long trek
to europe
where they know they'll get better
better goodies 10 million you know
no but europe's been decimated by by
like the global economy is just in in
flames
there's there's food shortages across
the border right but you look at europe
and then you look at afghanistan believe
me it's true you know
it's an upgrade it's you know and it's
one hell of an upgrade so that's why
people are constantly risking their
lives to lead to across the
mediterranean to i you know i'll tell
you this i went to uh greece and i
actually interviewed many refugees
and uh it was really amazing when i was
in athens and we saw some people drug
dealing and so we actually asked them
like hey would you want to do an
interview like we pointed the camera
down we didn't show their face and the
guy said that he came i think it's been
a long time since i watched the video
the video is still up on my youtube
channel you can watch it i think he was
from afghanistan and they were all given
these dreams of like how amazing it will
be if you can finally make it to europe
and then he realized it was all not true
that coming here was actually worse off
that you know you don't speak the
language that your only option is to be
a drug dealer and now you're at risk of
being imprisoned and you're you're not
free and it's scary when we when i went
to france
i went outside one of these refugee
centers and this was the sentiment they
said we were lied to we were told we
would come here we'd be given jobs and
homes instead we're suffering we have
it's worse than ever and if i could i'd
go back home
and then i went to uh lesvos
and there were people who were like
swimming to the island and they were
like it's a prison camp they're like we
came here and now we're in prison camps
it's torture and so they were constantly
rioting and i'm like
someone is telling these people some bs
well i mean to some extent it's the
people who
sell them immigration the people who
they get thousands of dollars from oh
yeah i'll carry i'll transit you across
the mediterranean for thousands of
dollars one of those boats that you know
that they try to stop got 50 100 people
in it you figure a couple grand a piece
on a on a leaky wooden boat with an
outboard motor i mean
you know that's that's why they're doing
it yeah and i think greece started like
scuttling ships just kicking them off
they would uh they were yeah they also
built a wall yeah it's very good they
built the wall came out yeah that's a
funny thing too i remember when uh when
i went to uh sweden then i went to
europe for the refugee crisis
donald trump was like we're gonna build
the wall it's going to be the greatest
wall and people kept saying walls won't
work because people will fly over and
then i'm like a three meter chain-link
fence reduced immigration into a
cameraman's country
uh by like 90
and the reason was the families couldn't
go over like the father probably could
but the mom and the kids couldn't climb
the fence so they'd go around well and
so just literally just a chain-link
fence well walls walls also work when
you when you man them yeah i mean they
don't they if if you somebody can throw
a ladder up and put it over and then
everybody can climb over yes but if
you've got you know
a moat with alligators well i mean
you've got hadrian's wall i mean it
it this is a system that worked for a
long time you've got the great wall of
china their
walls do work but they require staffing
yeah and you have to you know you have
to say sorry no but stop everybody no
but oh look look at the look at the
border we've got with canada we have
like 3 000 mile unprotected border so
yes if people want to go and go into
canada canada let's you know pre
pre-covered canada let anybody in now if
canada is also a
insane asylum uh that that just
restricts every right you could possibly
ever think you had
so pretty soon i guess we're gonna start
getting refugees from canada in the
united states so we'll have to worry
about that border too so this is uh uh
yeah i didn't see this story check it
out from reuters august 21st greece
completes border wall extension to deter
potential afghan migrants and uh there
it is i mean that's a hefty wall looks
like it's got barbed wire on it notice
it looks better built than ours yeah
what's up with that
it's a boundary with turkey it is
bollard fencing it's it's very very
similar but it does look better like
ours look rusty what was up with that
you know
they built it with rust
well also then you have to remember you
wonder if when the greeks build that
wall if they're also thinking about the
fact that they offer that they tend to
maybe go to war with the turks yeah like
okay
is this is this just one more sort of la
you know discouragement to the turks
roaming in and and attacking them
because they're still divide uh cyprus
you know it's like the the global order
is is is collapsing it's not just the
united states it's all of this
international trade you know uh uh when
we were hearing china was turning back
ships from american companies because
they wanted to keep the equipment with
the ppe and stuff like that just the
whole system is like what's that the
center cannot hold thing i mean you know
we we've we've all four of us lived in
unprecedented times and we're still
we're still benefiting from the post-war
boom from from world war ii world war ii
blew up
the
manufacturing and
you know the cities of pretty much
almost every civilized nation
and coming out of it you know it states
we didn't do it yeah so we built we
built tons of factories and then
soldiers came back they we had this
manufacturing base
and
we're very difficult to invade at least
as a military because where we're
located and we're armed to the teeth
yeah and so we still we're sort of
basking in that
but times change technology when when
the internet got invented
fortress america went away
because suddenly
russia china and iran anybody else who
wanted to involve themselves in america
could do so every single day they could
do it on the internet and social media
made it worse
it's not let's talk about you know
russia i'm talking about rt i'm talking
about you know chinese chinese media
chinese have
i
facebook won't allow itself to be based
in china oh we're not gonna go in china
there they got the great chinese great
firewall of china but meanwhile chinese
so chinese media companies have 751
million followers on facebook oh yeah
751 million followers
and pushing out pro china propaganda i
don't see facebook kicking them off i
don't see them restricting because they
don't dare mess with china and not to
mention in fact of course the money
they're getting from the ad placement on
those 751 million you know
users
yeah i was looking at facebook followers
man these politicians will have like 600
000 followers 300 000 followers people
i've never really even heard of or just
starting to hear of
it could be that could be a good thing
that they're becoming famous but they're
not really that special of people like i
don't they don't strike me as like
exceptionally talented or intelligent
maybe maybe intelligent maybe but they
just they put them so they ran for that
position they won the popularity contest
and now they're
super like 27 year old people have
hundreds of thousands of followers that
will never leave like for the rest of
their life those people know who they
are and
this it's disturbing it's disturbing
that a politician might make a life out
of it that that is not tenable
what's it we we live in a narcissistic
culture
we've exported it now to the whole world
to sell out your your ethics to get
reelected is like it brought us to where
we're at right now i think well it's
it's not just re-elected it's get famous
i mean yeah it's what was swole well you
know okay if you're if you're
uh
not especially famous congressman
and some hot young girl wants to
use the air quotes again euphemistically
date you
and
you know
alarm bells should go off in your head
if she's super hot and no chinese uh
somehow that sort of thing it should
should occur you see it all the time the
the the frumpy weird kid you know and
he's he's you know uh
just trying to be cool and fit in and
then all of a sudden this attractive
woman and he falls right for it
you know oldest turns out oldest yeah
oldest story in the book turns out she's
a chinese spy the whole time yeah you
know horatio sans was going through that
his statement was like when i was a kid
i was super unpopular and girls never
liked me and now he's super famous and
he's got all these like 17 year olds
coming up to him and crawling all over
them at bars so he's he's he was a
creepy weirdo weirdo when he was young
and he's an even creepier weirdo when
he's older love you love you horatio no
i'm just kidding i don't know anything
about that guy yeah and i don't know if
he was the one that said that i think
crystalia had said that that like when i
was a kid i had no and so yeah and now
he's older and he's like telling people
high school girls are talking to him for
the first time but telling people you're
a creepy weirdo when you were young
doesn't excuse you no it's disgusting
but now you understand why they go why
they're crazy like that
why would a famous ordinary people don't
have the opportunities to
be take advantage or be taken advantage
of the way famous people do and look at
look at athletes
athletes you know the the second they're
identified in pee wee sports you know
you're you're a oh my god you can throw
the ball oh my god you could run fast
you know you can hit the ball their
lives change
everybody tells them they're great
high school grade schools high schools
college bend over backwards the stars
of our pro sports or even the secondary
or tertiary players in our pro sports
were people who were stars every step
along the way in their lives ravens
right now have a backup quarterback who
actually beat lamar jackson the starting
quarterback when they're in high school
together and and you know and so
now he's a backup quarterback in the nfl
maybe he's the second year the second
quarterback
and
he's always been a star
when that happens you get
uh well you'll have women throw
themselves at you or men depending on
you know who you are uh financial
opportunities everybody thinks
everything you say and do is perfect
this is what happens to politicians
politicians get used to yes people
nobody one of the worst problems of dc
is nobody will tell you you know
everybody tell the boss hey boss that's
a really stupid idea
and so it becomes a culture i every time
i hire people i have to sit down and try
to explain to them yes you're allowed to
tell me i'm wrong matter of fact you're
encouraged to do it because sometimes
i'm an idiot that's a good point because
we hire them but then they hire a bunch
of yes men to surround them as they do
their job like their staff
these politicians or their politicians
because yes men surround them and tell
them to run
you know you know what it is uh i was
reading that uh celeb celebrities tend
to be narcissists because narcissists
tend to be the people who insert
themselves
and so when when you know when when it's
no surprise the people who are on tv all
the time are the people who demanded to
be on tv because they think they're
better than you
you get a bunch of narcissists and
sociopaths same thing is true
politicians there's the people who are
like i must run because only i can save
the people it's like you're a nut job
well but i mean that's how do you find
real leadership i mean that's that's all
people in washington my former
girlfriend might tell me one time i was
like well you don't have a big ego i
said you're just grading on a curve
you know it's just dc man you know
you're working on capitol hill everybody
in dc's got a huge ego just by
comparison yeah if we could find a way
to use ego for an energy source
dc would would power the universe yeah
the piezoelectricity
measuring the vibration of the brain
waves and creating electrostatic charge
wait wait wait you say brain waves in dc
i think you definitely would we would be
able to power a flashlight
i mean that's being generous did you get
an led flashlight how about that did you
work like in this in the dc machine i
i've worked
prior to working for
media critics i was in media i spent i
worked a couple daily papers i worked
for chronicle higher education
congressional quarterly
uh i've always worked in media or
in some form or now criticizing me do
you think this is something we've come
up with is that they say politics is
downstream from culture i think culture
is downstream from technology do you see
any any possibility that this system
could be solved politically
well the problem is
political will comes from people which
is back to culture
and you know that's so i mean it's all
it's all synergistic i mean there's no
you can't just take one piece out
donald trump was a great example of how
a combination of technology
and culture people people just wanting
change i know there's a lot of bernie
sanders people voting for donald trump
uh
people were frustrated with the powers
that be
you think people were frustrated the
powers of being when they voted for
donald trump you get three and a half
more years of what's been going on the
last seven months
and they'll be willing to vote for the
you know the ice cream salesman down the
street let's let's let's say
establishment politics we will call
substance x
and substance x has been pouring out of
all of our faucets
and our vents and our tvs it's the block
yeah it's just
sludge and then what happens is trump
comes along and he's like i'm gonna fix
it all it'll go away i'm the best no
more substance acts and people are like
i will take whatever i can get
but what happens is
he plugs it up it starts backing up in
the pipes and now biden is like ultra
concentrated substance acts it's like
it's like it builds up and then trump
holds it back for a few years and then
boom it comes out and you get everything
that people hated about establishment
politics going back for decades biden is
and and with a lot along along with the
media like a hyper concentrated version
of it well it's not just by it's
particularly yes along with the media i
mean
whether how much biden is doing to self
it's certainly the establishment that's
running dc right now is
you know the fact that the woke politics
the work you know stuff in school
critical race theory which is racism
all of this stuff is so overwhelming now
that it it's intended to overwhelm you
it's intended to make you lose hope it's
intended to make you give up and just
accept it we're living through a
cultural revolution
so yes culture so so
all that stuff is still downstream from
from culture but the difference is
culture is now hyper-powered with
technology that it's never seen before
china is doing a good job of mastering
it or at least riding the
riding the fenris wolf you know and not
having it eat them well that's that's
probably my dorkiest reference for the
evening
i think a lot about um deep fakes
because we're coming up on neural net
and deep fakes and like when we see a
deep fake video of a guy getting his
head cut off by a deep fake isis guy and
a deep fake american and we think it's
real and it might be a real fake
person's face on
and then the country goes to war because
of some deep faked
false flags running man
the map that the map where they map the
guy and they kill they they kill arnold
schwarzenegger and they just you know
they they map somebody they map
somebody's arnold's face on somebody
else that's with deep fakes and you know
who's most scared of it
politicians
they're afraid for the late hit where it
shows politician x
or substance x within a porno
yeah
uh someone tried making like that i
remember there's a viral video of like
the p tape and they're like it's it was
clearly staged and fed with an awkward
camera angle but it's not even
necessarily deep fakes it's when you
know how they do the the um
what is it called when they make the uh
oh is it that is a deep fake i guess
when they just make a fake person it's
not a real person the face doesn't exist
it's like oh yeah yeah yeah so it's not
like they'll take ian's face and put it
on your body it's like they literally
will artificially generate a face that
is of no person that's real yeah we got
that sites that now create just build
your own avenue do you guys remember
when they made uh the joe rogan
simulator where you could type in words
and it and then it was joe rogan saying
them oh no and it was near perfect yeah
and they they ended up taking it down i
guess you know
it's a little i don't know if joe came
out against it but like they can do they
took it down
yeah the guys who made it it was too
creepy or something
they were making videos of joe saying
crazy stuff to prove a point and it's
like
that's messed up dude yeah right but i
mean so they can
somebody posted a video just this week
where it was from canada and it was a
woman saying that isis are brothers
and
i raised question because it it didn't
lip sync out and i still don't know i'm
i haven't seen it that were where it
becomes
proof that it was phony so maybe it's
legit but it didn't it didn't look if
you watch the video
very clearly she's enunciating every
syllable correctly and she gets to
brothers and there's like a little blip
and then it doesn't look right and i'm
thinking is this phony so i mean i i
even tweeted people and i saw several
people raising the question
why haven't we seen more of this like
why haven't we seen you know aoc or
trump or biden or harris oh it is coming
yeah yeah he's right it's coming oh yeah
i mean
imagine what iran or russia could do
putting out a video of of biden and it's
just like deep faked in audio and it's
biden saying something and and they
wouldn't make it crazy like him saying
something like racial slur would be him
saying something like
yeah well what was i supposed to do
about these marines anyway you know what
we got more or less literally saying
ephem yeah just you know from from a
little oh here's a here's a tape because
but the deep state so you can't just do
that because it's it's too people will
be like eff i'm like there's no way
biden would say that his son died of
cancer and served but you know i mean i
think a lot of politicians would say
that people yeah people people would
believe it but i think if we saw a psyop
it wouldn't be that direct it would be
something like yeah we're sad to lose
them but we got more
well remember
we're living in the psyop and i don't
mean like some sort of a phony
artificial thing
the whole goal
of
foreign governments is to put us against
each other yeah and we're we're living
that every day and i mean the the us
them thing we live the stem thing and
i'm probably you know a good part of
that uh you know
fighting that but
if you look every single major issue now
that's fought on twitter
you run into the bot armies
and the bot armies
make it look
like
oh there's a lot of support for this
thing that well they're with their cares
they're not necessarily bots they're
sock puppets yeah sock puppet yeah but
phony accounts or small small accounts
and
you know that's why you don't read
replies don't read comments
yeah that's why i mean i look for real
people it's one it's one guy like when
you read your comments yeah and you have
like 10 comments where they're like
you're ugly you're fat you're a loser
it's one guy it's god speaking to you
through whatever what's funny is when
you you know you delete the one and
another one just picks up right right
where the one left off like of course
it's the same person they think you
don't
you know or when they accidentally use
their socks without realizing it yeah i
forgot to switch their accounts yeah
this is oh another zero follower june
2021 account but nevertheless
politicians and business people don't
understand this yep flat out don't so
when tennessee went to
constitutional carry for guns god bless
them
the i saw some people responding to the
governor saying oh thank you very much
this is great we want next thing the
parade of the accounts and you could
tell some people who are on there didn't
get what was happening
and that's
truly unsophisticated i mean that's
that's you know garbage
you know
political maneuvering
the democrats have a couple
bot armies or or soccer count armies
russia has at least one or two china has
won
iran doesn't shockingly and they don't
understand you can block people uh
so they're very unsophisticated but
we've now discovered the taliban is so
sophisticated that even the media are
speculating that they've hired a pr firm
so so i mean this is this is affects our
politics
every single day and it's designed from
foreign governments and even people in
our country to pitt us against one
another
yep let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and check out the cast
castle because we have started ramping
up production we're getting almost daily
vlogs out right now and if you want to
see the inner workings of what's
happening here at the studio it's a
whole lot of just i don't know people
are skating we had a fog machine you got
a really cool
cool
facility here you really do and we
started we started this show the cast
castle vlog you know earlier this year
and now we've ramped up production so
we're getting to the groove figuring
things out the other day i went down
into the green room where we invite our
guests and it was full of smoke smoke
machine
and we have like our guest daniel turner
is like sitting there in a shroud of fog
and i'm like what are these people doing
through the mist and they're so cool and
i'm like guys and they're like oh
i'm like get a fan what are you doing we
have people coming in the house but it's
funny oh isn't it sure
youtube.comcastcastle let's read some
super chat smash that like button
for ian
if you smash that like button today a
sad ian will be brightened by your
contribution of one like that's true
thank you
thank you how was he and smash it for me
all right
smash it for me silly bring me back his
place is cool and i actually don't live
all that far away a sad old man
smash it for the creepy old guy who's
who's who's hanging out with with people
half his age on friday night i don't
know how the magic user yeah exactly how
old are you
oh
i don't want to say because i don't
think i don't think
ian's old i'm older he's 50 40.
almost i'm almost but i'm fine
you were quick to be like 40. let's just
just go for og and stick there yeah
i'm 73.
uh let's read some of these super chats
harito says no luke we nuke
yeah no rudkowski we pukowski yeah i saw
that yes a couple days ago
if if people aren't going to be sending
loving messages to luke every day to let
him know i mean why would he come back
and the new studio is around the corner
so we're going to have much easier to
accommodate more people and that's going
to be a whole lot of fun i'm so excited
we just ordered a whole bunch of these
led light bars so
the whole top of the room is going to be
lined by these led bars and then there's
going to be a halo above the table so
lighting will be perfect i'm surprised
you didn't go for this for the circular
table though you know to do the whole
not you know knights of the round table
thing yeah that'd be too difficult
you know like you'd be sitting next to
someone like two feet from you like try
and talk to him you know so we have like
we we can accommodate i think up to
eight people now yeah not that we'll do
it because that would be a cacophony of
voices yes
it'd be like twitter oh yeah yeah yeah
it's already hard enough with four five
people leave one seat just for bots yeah
seriously
we get a bidenbot yeah
come on man 360 camera and one of the
seats so that you can watch and as if
you're there you can still we could do
that that'd be cool you could steal the
animatronic joe biden because it really
looks
exactly like joe biden and talks exactly
like joe biden because he's animatronic
i want that thing all right let's read
some more we got it's me saying it's tom
mcdonald friday dummies is out yeah wow
there's there's so many excellent lines
in tom mcdonald music that i'm just like
i like it he's a philosopher man i like
listening to him yeah dummies is good i
haven't memorized the lyrics but i
remember sitting there being like
there's he's got it like there's lines
in that you should check out dummy's man
tom mcdonald dude yes
all right let's see what we got here
ctrl alt delete says i love papa joe
take your sum and go back to sleep
sheeple we are living in the times
between 84 and brave new world yeah
but at least brave new world was a
satire
yeah we're living in the real version
yeah interesting chris says couldn't
find stream today had to come to uh
channel directly to find it normally
it's on my home page figured y'all
should know i watch every night chris
thank you for seeking out the show i
will say
that uh we were having weird hiccups
where the show was cutting out and our
internet's perfect and this is only the
only other time this has happened has
been when we talked about uh china and
censorship yep so i wonder if they don't
like you
that would that would shock me so much
yeah
let's see i support free speech i spent
all my days like fighting idiots who
want to censor stuff yeah i'd be i'd be
totally stunned
austin shafer with a very intelligent
point that i didn't even consider
tim
one way we have to pos uh one one thing
i assume you mean we have to possibly be
ready for a forced vaccine coming from
insurance companies for health insurance
easily could be rejected on rates raised
for health or life insurance if you do
not have the vaccine yeah or what if
they say access to you know medicare and
medicaid you have to be up to date with
all of your shops well they could just
they could simply say if you're going to
get any government program
yeah easy yep easy
i mean is that wrong
yes
if you if in order to get so it's the
question of
if we're going to be paying you to take
care of your medical
ailments like we as a community but you
aren't taking care of yourself why
should we pay for it well so then where
do you draw the line do you okay you're
too fat right okay so you got to lose 20
pounds oh wait you're now do hey your
your um skateboard activities they're
risky you're going to hurt yourself so
you got to stop that um let's see you
drive too much you drive too fast you
got we caught a speeding ticket so we're
going to take that i mean this a this is
a genuine twilight zone episode where
the the guy wanted to i think he wanted
to lose weight and then they went after
his cigarettes and you know it's like or
vice versa i can't remember which one it
was but i mean this is they can by that
rationale they can control everything
you do
these doctors who say oh well i'm not
going to treat cova patients who don't
have the vaccine well are you treating
fat people are you treating you know
uh people who
don't take care of themselves in any
other way that was my observation too
but i would make it the more analogous
comparison between something like an std
which you can spread to other aids
100 perfect comparison is aids and you
know where it was oh you have to be
compassionate people are still living
their lives well then
you know the very people who said you've
got to be compassionate now i want to
say oh you know i want to destroy you
want to destroy your life
you know i i don't like i don't like the
idea of forcing people to do something
i've said this before i've got the
vaccine i'm sure some people who are
listening right now are freaked out or
annoyed by that it gave me 100 access to
seeing my dad yes my dad's in long-term
care and when you get the vaccine you
know the facility he's in a lot of
people died from cove and my father
actually had coveted and somehow beat it
even at 92.
but
uh but when you when you've got the
vaccine i can get in the seam and so you
know
that's a that's a that's a risk um
do you mean based on regulations or do
you mean based on safety okay so based
on safety at that facility because they
had so many so many problems all the
facilities have had to rain things in
because there's been so many seniors who
were killed you get one kovi case in a
facility you know these are the people
who've got comorbidities and they're old
and they're the most likely to have that
and that's and that's where uh you know
cuomo
killed all these people yeah that that's
not that's what i mean
one of the reasons why they want cuomo
to go away is there four other
democratic governors who did the same
thing yep and you don't see that story
anywhere so so i mean but that said
i think the entirely rational approach
is simply okay i chose my own health
care
don't don't force me to choose my own
health care
that's and that's that's
forcing you to choose your own health
care is like right you better pick what
you want to do all right you better pick
what we want you to do that's what the
left does all the time you better
it's like like um
oh what's the family that's got all the
kids um
the duggars okay so the left will say
we believe that you know women's right
to choose oh one's right to choose so
but then somebody goes and has a bunch
of kids they freak out it's like well
you chose you chose poorly yeah so we
don't approve well you ever see the
south park episode where they're having
the election between a giant douche and
a turd sandwich
and then i think it's like stan says i
don't care about voting and they'll get
mad at him and then finally he he's like
you know what okay i'm gonna vote and
kyle is all like yes vote for my guy and
then he sees that stan voted for the
other guy he's like wait what are you
doing no no don't vote for them what are
you doing you're voting for the wrong
person yeah they want you to vote when
you vote for the for their guy
it's uh i one of the things that's gone
viral repeatedly is the seinfeld episode
where kramer goes and does the the aids
monk and he's he doesn't want to wear
the button
he doesn't want to wear it oh right
right right yeah where the aids flag and
they beat him up yeah it's like okay but
wait a second i'm walking he clearly
cared about the issue but no they were
like wear it he's like no
he's america i don't have to do it and
that's and that's the thing the more
they push any and it doesn't matter what
the issue is it doesn't matter whether
it's covid or censorship or anything the
more government
media business
coordinate
and say this is what you must do
the more there's a good chunk of the
population that says well that's of
course not the thing i want to do
especially against resistance that's
already formed if there was no
resistance and it was an obvious problem
most people i think could get down with
self-mandation like
i bring this up if people were falling
down on the street stumbling over and
bleeding out of their face from this
thing i would not have a problem with
the government being like look we're not
going to take a 60 percent of our
population die to this thing well i mean
that was smallpox back in the day yeah
smallpox did like really really high
death rate it's like 20 or something
wasn't it i don't remember this
but it was massive much much worse than
anything we can even comprehend let's
let's read some more super chats we got
a couple people saying that we're being
censored cole deluxe production says
your stream no longer shows up on my
front page recommendations and it now
continues to freeze when i have full
bars of cellular data totally not
suspicious is it and we also have full
bars on our end so this is an internal
youtube problem
yeah this is interesting elizabeth
carmela comedian says hey guys i don't
know if you guys ever used to watch that
show house house is awesome with you
laurie
he used ivermectin many times in that
show to treat his crazy cases
when i first heard that he was talking
about it i already knew what it was
because of that show interesting let's
go check that out i wonder if they'll
take those episodes down or wonder if
they already have yeah ultra
ultra squash says hey tim been watching
since i was 13 17 now thanks wow
you gotta you gotta you gotta inspire
children you know to to be better people
and that's the goal right that's one of
the reasons why we're doing the vlog
because we don't want to be overly
political we don't want to be overly
negative we want to put resources to
doing things that are fun and exciting
and inspirational
and positive you know and we want people
to to respect freedom and individuality
so
i was going to say i got i got the the
leap on this because i've followed you
for 10 years because because i go all
the way back to occupy days
wow
which is 10th anniversary coming up next
month that's right that's right yeah
17th
all right let's see jay says do you have
any recommendations for new people to
learn linux programming i'm looking into
a career change i want to try this oh
you want to learn to code
but but if you post that on youtube we
can get banned yeah you'll get the yeah
yeah i don't i am not i'm not a coder i
don't know i don't know that's the short
answer i wish i could give you some
advice um i think you can like go online
and get videos of the programming and
then just
follow along with it on another monitor
if you have an extra monitor and then
just do the things as they say step by
step and you'll learn the process the
languages
are like a big database of information
that you'll need to memorize over time
but the more you enter the stuff the
faster you learn it there are lots of
sites that do things like classes for
painting and you know calligraphy and i
imagine that at least one of them would
have some kind of coding 100 and i bet
some of the posters right now who are
responding or responding to him and
saying oh here's where you get
the lead developer of mine's learned
that way mark harding
watched videos and taught himself
all right cycantia says hey there tim
have you heard of a little shop called
5-0 skate shop a certain operator named
after a round breakfast pastry also have
you ever watched the clone wars rebels
or a bad batch loving the members only
segments i have not watched any of those
shows and i don't know the skate shop
sorry
david frye with the one dollar super
chat thank you so much for your support
all the super chats we love them
x asks so did you sue the fact checkers
on facebook
so when for me in my case i didn't
actually post the the the thing that was
checked and so
the challenge is
it was someone screenshotting a tweet of
mine but it wasn't content that if that
was of mine it wasn't negatively
impacting a page so there's no damages
it's just them lying and so the
challenge with defamation cases you got
to prove damages well and also you've
got to have
an army of lawyers i mean facebook
facebook can you know reign money like
they're going to a strip club and you've
got to be able to pay up for that and
it's hard hard to do really is oh this
is important little tails farm says tim
our chickens hatch tomorrow and we will
be filming it on our youtube channel for
everyone to see also we bought a huge
mini house shed
converting into our version of chicken
city love the show nice
we have uh probably the worst possible
time to be doing this
um well actually i mean maybe little
tales i don't know you know better than
i do we have 12 eggs in the incubator
now
and they're going to hatch in about a
week just shy of two weeks
they're not going to be able to go
outside it's going to be cold you know
so they're going to keep them inside or
build something for them i guess the
three we have three babies right now
they're two weeks old officially and so
they're running around and they're doing
chicken stuff
there's a big house
yeah we got like we we we just had to ex
so they were in the brooder box for a
little while
but now they're getting too big and
they're getting cramped so now we we set
up an even bigger space
you know it's like a guinea pig play pen
area thing or whatever it's like a cage
and so now they can run around and do
their chicken thing and they just they
poop where they walk and then they try
to eat it it's awful
you see chris playing with the one on
the vlog yeah and they didn't want to go
back in the cage they tried to jump out
yeah you put your hand in they'll jump
on your hand super and then they'll try
and climb up your arm
well because they want to get out they
want to run around do chicken stuff you
know we should get make it like a big
area for them to plan if we can
right now they're really small they
don't need that big of an area i bet
they would love it but the the the
previous chicken family you know for
chicken city they have the whole farm
area and they they roll around in the
dirt all day and it's really funny just
make sure you protect them from aerial
attack yes uh my niece has chickens and
they notice a couple chickens
disappeared and then they realize they
had a hawk in the neighborhood and then
they had to build a roof on their roof
you know the whole area because the
chickens were going out and
yeah we have a roof on one part of it
right now the actual coop is sealed yeah
but i mean when they go out yeah they
were getting hawked
it was like hawk to slayer for another
movie reference for people don't
remember i don't want to wait around and
then one day be like uh
one of them got one of the chickens i
wonder if we can
yeah because they all have names we
named them all oh well then you
definitely gotta deal with that i had a
hawk in my neighborhood i lived in
suburbia i had a hawk in my neighborhood
and then when it went away the the
dynamic of birds the birds over bred in
my area went kind of nuts interesting
yeah i was like i wanted the hawk to
come back because the birds were like
flying into my house windows and stuff
like that for a little while wow come on
all right this is great steven heinold
says tim why do you always mention
dubuque iowa in your analogies did
something nefarious happen to you there
and you're dropping him hints for us to
solve your secret like a large tim cast
easter egg it's true buried did you did
you proper coordinate did you post hang
yo like uh hang a flag up in dubuque and
we're waiting for everybody on the
internet to figure out where it is it's
because dubuque is the perfect not big
city city so random so it's like
you know if you said like oh in new york
something happened it's like no no when
you want to mention like
uh middle america like dubuque iowa man
i'm looking it up right now i guess you
could say omaha almost i've been in
omaha before there's a there's a lot
greater corn oh population is 50
there you 57
absolutely what i'm saying it's perfect
little middle american time kind of my
hometown nobody nobody gets the salute
reference everybody nobody watch hee haw
no it's too lost
jordan says tim the point dorsey is
making is valid yes it's censorship but
at the same time it can't it can be
dangerous for millions of people using
social media to organize against the
government it is a threat and he just
called it out it was that in reference
to dorsey called what out is this what
his uh anatomy of the state
i mean his post was my assumption was it
was informing people of rothbard's
writing definitely which is calling the
state parasitic it was like he was
calling for help from inside the machine
that's right that's what i thought it
was
it's like you're looking at the screen
and his hand is reaching i'm still here
i'm still jack
but there is a huge gap between
organizing its estate and causing and
causing an actual insurrection sort of
like you know portland uh as opposed to
posting stuff about covid where that
where uh twitter disagrees with you
that's kind of a significant difference
yeah i want to upgrade the united states
but sometimes that means twisting
aspects of it that i'm afraid that if it
gets too too much censorship that we
won't even be able to discuss the things
that we need to fix well at one billion
percent the point
if we can't even talk about the problems
if we can't even the whole definition of
a scientific freaking method is
you come up with something and then
other people get to challenge it in the
normal society otherwise what you've got
is the vatican from copernicus's day oh
wait you came up with science sorry
we have faith and that's what this is
this is the people on twitter they've
turned
science
into faith scientism you know and you
get the washington post i love this we
did a study about the washington post
washington post is all the time oh well
you guys are not you know focusing on
the science washington post last year
devoted by our calculation 45
full equivalent of 45 full pages 2
drumroll please
astrology
okay so the sciency people are devoting
the equivalent size of an entire
daily newspaper big daily newspaper in
the nation's capital to astrology which
is bogus and then turning around and
calling people out for for their daring
to disagree with fauci and such yikes
all right alex aitken says watch the
video by marine ltc stuart sheller he
talks about how people at the top need
to be held accountable like the people
at the bottom are his video will end his
17-year career wow man was that stuart
sheller s-c-h-e-l-l-e-r
i'll check it out for sure good for him
yeah definitely
we have a great super chat but the
message was retracted oh no no no thank
you anyway
um horace seymour also mentioning marine
lieutenant colonel stu sheller who was
relieved of command in afghanistan for
speaking out about the pentagon lack of
planning bravo to him wow dang
all right let's see
steven says i wouldn't be surprised if
the taliban sold the list of americans
biden gave to them and isis got to the
checkpoint with one of the names oh wow
yeah well yeah you're expecting the
the terrorists to be honorable even if
they don't all like isis because they're
you know
isis now isis k which by the way is just
like you know some sort of made-up term
that we're supposed to focus on it
stands for islamic state corazon which
is an ancient area of afghanistan
but i mean so so yes there's been
conflict between isis and taliban but
are we supposed to trust that everybody
got access to that list is oh an
honorable terrorist sure no no
all right let's see alex kelman says
been watching since march 2020 also
timcast.com member first super chat walt
disney world is requiring all cast
members employees to get the jab by
halloween or be terminated 76 000 people
in florida wow terminated boy sounds
that's just not the wording i don't want
to use if i was disney the mass the mass
resignation the great resignation
they're calling it this is going to be
uh it's going to be absolutely
exacerbated by the police now in chicago
are saying if you met if you push this
mandate we're not going to show up for
work it's on you
so many people are going to just be like
nope they said well we're going to say
no i was going to say the truckers are
the real honor the truckers have said if
we're if you're gonna you're gonna mess
with us when we show up with
with goods
if you're gonna say oh you don't have
you you don't have the facts we're not
gonna let you in or something like that
you're gonna give us a hard time trucker
said they're gonna walk i said
good luck cities a number said that
within a year you will see like 500 000
more resignations with 5 million more
resignations i don't know but it said
that of the current workforce and then
they specified the work the workforce is
employed and people looking for
employment though those people are
considered in the workforce even though
they don't have a job that's insane to
me yeah but they can speculate but they
can be considered unemployed but they're
part of the workforce because they're
actually because they're so actively
looking once you've stopped you you've
hit a point it's backwards the the uh
you're right to bring it up but what
what this means is
when we are like the unemployment rate
is currently at eight percent they're
not including people who have given up
so if you're like i can't get a job i
quit i'm gonna go live in the dirt they
don't consider you unemployed right what
yeah these numbers are twisted yes all
numbers are twisted all numbers
government numbers are twisted but i
mean that
you really haven't you read the enemy
anatomy of a state no i haven't the
state isn't paris i heard that i should
read it
you're reminding me why i like where i
work because we do not have a vax
mandate and
you know
and i can say you know you don't let i
want everyone to understand this if you
as a business require people to get the
vaccine your employees you are legally
responsible for any adverse reaction now
i personally think the vaccine is safe
but i don't think people should be uh
being mandated and there's i've
mentioned this before there's like a
scaling issue with trying to be more
libertarian like respecting a small
business and what their choices are as
an individual but it gets it's difficult
when you scale up the point is
if you work for a company
you know i'll tell people a few things
to ease your mind simply draft out a
letter saying that you know ask your
employer if they mandate it say just you
know sign this and i'll gladly go to the
doctor and make them sign a document
saying we will
claim full responsibility for all
you know medical issues that arise
following this you know treatment or
whatever see what your boss tells you
i think uh a lot of people will tell you
no we're not signing but it's the the
sea i think it's the cdc that actually
says they have they're liable no matter
what if they mandate it so if it no no
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's osha osha said
that if your job mandates it they are
responsible because it's considered you
know requirement for work so like if
your job requires you to um
you know wear a safety harness as you
climb when the safety harness breaks
it's their fault they're responsible for
that because they made you do it
same thing is true here so i think a lot
of these businesses don't realize that
and when it comes to like you know your
company's saying you don't mandate it we
don't mandate it here because i will not
assume liability for people's health
choices that's entirely on them not me
and we are pro-freedom i'm very
pro-freedom
that's right
all right let's see we got here
ben macklin says satire cite the duffel
blog hit the nail on the head with their
headline quote general milly regrets not
including vietnam war history book on
reading list
indeed the ibram candy reference that's
a that's a real good thing the duffel
blog is only second to babylon d for
real cool stuff
babylon b is prophetic man it's kind of
scary yeah you can look back in time and
see their articles actually come true
they keep they keep a list of the things
it just
it's still for all that it did was my
still favors the washing machine where
because it got it got fact checked you
remember that oh wait they they actually
don't put their story cena doesn't
actually put their stories in a giant
washington washing machine
eric miller says my third time super
chatting this two scientists are trying
to build a star trek like impulse engine
reported on bloomberg very interesting
all right the reaper medic says cpd and
cfd are united in total opposition to
the chicago vax mandate most i know are
willing to walk or take leave myself
included both departments are already
short on manpower this is going to get
very interesting soon i actually know
people who work in uh in those
departments and they have expressed
um
yeah they they might just walk well i
mean nationwide the whole
endless war on police is a nationwide
maine
meant that police departments are
struggling to find fine people because
who wants to go in an era where you know
the politicians won't back you and your
you can't police
i i know in my own county they had nine
graduates from the last uh police
academy classes smallest in history wow
that's not cool
kubana says i changed my career to
political sciences there's got to be a
way to fight back republicans need young
blood
i mean and and balls too
republicans need uh gumption yeah the
republican party just like sits around
and they're like i would definitely
encourage anyone to to dispense with the
word fight don't use the word fight
because no one wants to build yeah
people don't want to fight you right now
they want to create cool stuff and
they'll like you if you make cool stuff
build build build build create
make yeah makers
all right let's see we got here
oh he just jumped on me again
youtube always does that
all right let's see where were we yikes
okay let's see
joe f says please read me rosa core
please look into her videos she
conducted presentations about 10 years
ago and what she discusses is coming to
fruition over time and exponentially oh
i'm sorry exponentially increasing in
velocity green anything interesting uh
exponentially of course is the biden
quote he said exponential yes
i was gonna i thought it was a typo at
first i was gonna say exponentially and
then i realized what they were doing
with exponentially and i was like
i had a really good super chat now it
when i can't see where it is now uh tina
collette says tim i watch cast castle
every day take this super chat and buy a
hammer seeing your crew use pistols bats
and other stuff makes me crazy and yell
at the tv
that's funny for some reason when i was
trying to open a box they handed me one
of these throwing axes that was why it's
like a going theme on the castle now
people people open boxes with the
throwing axes
at least they didn't throw the throwing
axe it's very chill i was like someone
had like a knife i can open this box
like here and i'm like all right
sax i guess
is it a future episode you're going to
be you know on your skateboard throwing
hacks
oh that's cool
jimmy kinto says so when are you going
to have an exclusive alex jones
interview on your website so more can
flock to it lol
um we may have an announcement in the
next few days about something that i
think will break the internet
alex jones featuring a special guest oh
yes i'm really excited alexander himself
alex jones and a special guest we're
we're and since i'm privy to this i
could people the other part of this
usual pro i'm not gonna say that part of
the usual propaganda like why you should
watch but i can just say he's right it
really will break the freaking internet
it will okay
it's really a cool idea well so what
we're trying to do is we're trying to we
don't want to do like crossfire
necessarily we had you know we had vosh
we had charlie and that was really fun
we don't want to do like this very
obvious like left versus right we want
to do like people who don't make sense
sitting next to each other yes this is
perfect so you know that's kind of the
goal moving forward just to like expand
and it's kind of like to bring people
together from different areas so we
really want to do like a crypto expert
with you know someone who's overtly
culture war and like to see where they
come together with their ideas and like
what they can what they're concerned
about that'll be a lot of fun but uh
we're hoping to have uh
alex back very very soon with a really
fun guest i don't want to say anything
like obviously we're talking about alex
jones i don't want to say anything
definitive yet because we don't have a
date and we're trying to make figure out
you know if we can schedule these people
properly
but i think it's looking promising you
know uh we've had alex on a couple times
we're always we're always we always love
to have him back so and you can let us
know when they censor it yeah we will we
will yep
yeah yeah yeah
because that's that's i don't think
that'll happen this time
i think this is going to be a sillier
conversation than anything and it'll be
a lot of fun and just you know awesome
yeah super chill thing about the world
well maybe not chill is the right word
all right
there's there's gonna be no chill in the
in that zip code
i noticed about censorship that
the act of it just by definition of the
word like if you make a post and i look
at it and i decide to let it be there
i'm censoring it but the set the sensor
is deciding if it if it is or isn't just
the act of deciding is the censorship
it's not the taking down of so just
having sensors in place is like having
people having people who have the power
to shut down your thought you might like
the minds uh set up right now it's it's
a jury system where if something gets
reported for violating terms it goes to
a random selection of users that have to
vote if they think it was a violation
and then if it if it is if agreed upon
by the jury then it's sent yeah so
that's better than what they set up for
facebook is basically you have the mob
and if you get enough peep mob people
just click the click then you get then
you get your post taken there
right
mz kim says get a dog to protect
chickens we actually have two dogs that
are running around at all times uh and
they you know they're peeing everywhere
so we're pretty safe from predators yeah
we we used to have deer that would come
out with the dogs chasing away now yeah
well one of the dogs was super cute i
can't the other one was tied up so i
couldn't i didn't get to say
they're the best oh yeah fake co-workers
sony james says tim i'm finding it real
hard to be positive especially seeing
the quarantine facilities go up in
australia any examples of history where
the people fought back and won against a
minority of the totalitarians without
other countries aid who had skin in the
game
man i don't know
yeah somebody from somebody from
australia was telling me that quarantine
is just for people coming back into
australia that's not true um i'm just
saying that's but that's what they're
that's what they're putting out so it's
like you know oh the camps are just for
prisoners of war oh the camps are just
for people with typhus oh the camps are
just for the dissidents oh the camps are
just for people we don't like what's
funny is you mentioned cancer it's one
of the big jerks on twitter is george
takai who
grew up in one of the camps
built and put there by fdr a democrat
and he spends all his time bashing
republicans
sorry let's ask him about the quarantine
camps in you know in australia and see
what he says i think i said some somehow
if he doesn't
he doesn't run that account i'm pretty
sure i guess but if that if somebody put
but he goes on television goes on media
all over the place somebody somebody put
me in a camp as a little kid
and that political party is still strong
i'd probably hold a grudge just saying
i don't know he's got he's got he's got
a lot of boots to let you know he's got
it someone's got to do it his first name
is hosato changed to george at some
point
i like that guy
all right let's see we'll do we'll do
just a couple more here garhant says i
just want michael malus in real jester's
outfit then tim brings out a little
puppet of michael as jester that is a
really weird but good idea to be
hilarious
like having like a little puppet
michael malus i thought you're gonna
have them stripped down into those
underwears he sells that's right yeah
[Laughter]
all right let's see oh i could have done
without that image yeah yeah
it's on his instagram if you want to see
it oh yeah if you want to waffle sensei
says tim good sir when are you going to
upload the original alex jones michael
malus episode to the website i don't
know if we we do we do have we still
have it oh we can let's put it on rumble
yeah it's on my laptop okay cool yeah
because i know it is up on itunes and
stuff isn't it yeah yeah the audio i
think oh maybe not no i think it is okay
you had me take it down off the podcast
platforms too did i really yeah you did
because you're like nope nope nope take
it down take it down i was like okay all
right okay all right we'll put it up
right now all right we'll figure it out
yeah yeah there was a lot of there was a
lot of confusion around that and we
didn't know exactly what was going on or
why or who was coming after us but then
we forgot about it so we can put it up
on the website right now
um cool all right struggling on youtube
says inside info that ca hospital is
mandating the vaccine it informed
employees that if they are coveted
positive but asymptomatic to go ahead
and come into work it's not about health
it never was
yikes man all right we'll do one more
btk says when millie meets evacuated
troops who had to leave the others
behind and the families of the dead
they'll teach him all colors of rage
all right my friends it's been a fun
friday night thank you for all so much
for hanging out go to timcast.com become
a member we're going to put up that alex
jones episode on rumble immediately as
soon as lydia gets a chance to do it
with my laptop yeah yes and then uh so
so um maybe by tomorrow morning i think
you can expect it to be up and uh man we
we screwed that one up we should have
headed up immediately we just kind of
dropped the ball in that one i think you
know what happened is that we were gonna
like we were always planning on getting
on the website but then but then i
immediately shifted focus to rebook them
do the show again and then like a week
later we just did the show again because
i was like ain't nobody gonna bring us
down and but we'll get it up uh so you
can follow us on the show at timcast irl
you can follow me personally at tim cast
check out
youtube.comcastcastle for all the vlog
shenanigans dan did you want to shout
out yeah absolutely follow me on twitter
at dan gainer d-a-n-g-a-i-n-o-r
if you get censored which i know a lot
of you are getting censored you get
censored go to censortrack.org we got a
whole little form for you to fill out
fill it out because
it's important
you're doing really important work man
thanks for coming this has been right
this has been fun and by the way give
lots of nice comments about me so they
bring me back please do i love you
thanks man uh follow me ian
crossland.net and ian crossland on
social media if you want to get down hit
me up and i'm loving that dan is an
older version of all the nerdy guys that
i hang out with every day i think that's
awesome you guys are free to follow me
on twitter at sourpatchlist as i
continue my quest to have more followers
and sour patch kids
we will see you all uh at the cast
castle vlog youtube.comcastcastle thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
next time
you